it's a duty that has punctuated her
70-year reign only twice as she missed
it when she was pregnant now she's
handing over the responsibility for this
time at least
my lords and members of the house of
commons the queen continues to
experience episodic mobility problems
the palace said and in consultation with
her doctors has reluctantly decided that
she will not attend the state opening of
parliament tomorrow at her majesty's
request and with the agreement of the
relevant authorities the prince of wales
will read the queen's speech on her
majesty's behalf with the duke of
cambridge also in attendance
the palace keen to stress that son and
grandson will open it jointly as
councillors of state authorised by a
one-off letters patent from the queen
the queen will be immensely disappointed
not to fulfill one of her chief
constitutional roles but the great thing
about the regency act of 1937 is that
her son the prince of wales and her
grandson the duke of cambridge can step
forward and ensure that the monarchy
does what it must and opens parliament
effectively so that the political
process can carry on morning in recent
months the queen herself has admitted
struggling
well as you can see i can't move
and catching covid also increased
concerns about her health it does leave
one very tired and exhausted doesn't it
but at 96 she has seemed on good form as
the preparations build up her platinum
jubilee i thought it had to be upside
down for the pressure
[Laughter]
and just as it was at prince phillips
memorial plans are now being put in
place to cut down on how much she has to
walk but other events have felt like a
step too far the prince of wales at the
commonwealth day service and the maundy
service taking on his mother's role this
is absolutely unprecedented um yes the
queen has not attended um the state open
of parliament on two occasions before
but um lord lord commissioners um
stepped into the breach with the law
chancellor as the lead of the law
commissioners delivering the speech
this is the first time councillors of
state have been appointed the softly
softly approach to transition has been
happening for some time prince charles
placing her wreath at the cenotaph
prince william representing her on
overseas tours
to mark the start of the jubilee year
the queen pledged to continue to serve
her country
she is not stepping away but this is a
moment where she appreciates her heirs
must symbolically step in rhiannon mills
sky news